[Music]
start over start over why would you
start over
well you're kind of starting over so
tragic story mm-hmm I will profoundly
apologize on the air that I made John
Luke roll back his save without knowing
that he over wrote his way farther save
in Kingdom Hearts 3 mm-hmm so he has
made the ultimate sacrifice today I have
to show you the Pirates of the Caribbean
world and Kingdom Hearts 3 I basically
like I said lost him 12 hours and a lot
of sort of secrets but I I lost all of
the work I did the postgame work I did
to get the secret ending so when I when
they put that up on Thursday I'm just
gonna watch on YouTube cuz I know you
know and I know that I know whoever's in
all of the work yes see it and I deserve
to see it but unfortunately I cannot
watch it on my own console
anyway Kingdom Hearts 3 anyways let's do
it Jack Sparrow so this is a missin late
game stuff for those of you watching I
imagine if you're watching this you
probably are not playing it because it's
Kingdom Hearts day so yeah launch day 2
you're probably watching in the game
yeah I figure do we go a little farther
than we did last time yeah this is one
of the late Disney worlds you can you
can do and this is probably the most
interesting area basically oh you lunch
I feel like I owe them maybe a little
more than that this point I might owe
him like I don't I don't know what
exactly but I feel like lunch is not
enough what's with the spoilers I don't
know I don't necessarily consider it
spoilers can also considering so many
people have streams all weekend yeah
there are people there dreamin like this
SEC they were streaming this they were
shown the ending of the game and they
should not have been we are abiding by
the rules laid out to us now we're just
basically it's like we were only allowed
to show the first couple of Disney World
yeah but now the game is out or it's
been out exactly so we have the
opportunity to show some later Disney
worlds but again none of this is really
gonna get into
don't worry spoilers or anything like
that so but if you are worried then
don't want to now yeah the ones in the
SCAF you're worried about support I mean
if you're worried about spoilers I mean
you wouldn't be in here right at this
point you should be playing the game Oh
or or if you can't play the game yet I
would still just recommend not being
here yeah exactly but again I'm not
gonna like talk about it so wait you
have this on ps4 as well is that what
you're saying i pre-ordered forever ago
oh god he has four copies so you're
gonna start all over not not immediately
I've in my head I was like oh maybe like
later this year I would if I whenever I
eventually replayed the game I would
maybe do it on this yeah because the
copy they sent for pre-release was an
Xbox copy sure Brian played on his for
Ryan brings up a good point if you
haven't watched it yet you should watch
John Luke Lucy and Richard and I'm not
sure if there was anyone else on that
collaboration but the history of Kingdom
Hearts if you wanted to kind of like
know where you're getting yourself into
if you didn't play some of the other
Kingdom Hearts or just in Play Kingdom
Hearts in general so you could get
caught up definitely go watch that it's
a up on the side and YouTube it's pretty
pretty good video I would say not just
because I work here and I realize I'm
wearing game swatch shirt but you know
it was a hard work and it definitely
shows
I'll put the game on crowd mode when I
replay it thanks Gareth or subscribe
appreciate that you guys didn't know
GameSpot live live when did Friday 1:00
a.m. Fridays is usually actually
community Fridays which Johnny Ben Ben
Ben's actually had a bad back for a
couple days I did blame Ben earlier for
this last day because I had planned
another stream today but then it kind of
revolved around having been around and
he wasn't here although I guess I could
have just asked you the same thing but I
don't know then I asked you this and
mistakes were definitely made someone
else said that I definitely owe you
lunch for more than one day that seems
kind of accurate maybe two three maybe
three three three seams I don't know you
have to look at that I lost at lunch
lunch / 12 hours yeah so like does one
lunch equate for hours I don't know
actually one lunch over two days hard to
say Stephen makes here if you don't have
to spam I see you don't worry
Rory be he's not a fan of Kingdom Hearts
sweet I don't even know if he's played
it though yeah I like it I think it's
fun game I really like the combat I like
all the Disney worlds yeah it's like
crazy meshing of the two yeah I think
it's pretty good
Kingdom Hearts Kingdom Hearts fans I
think will be very happy
it's nice it's sort of like the and
everyone everyone's talking about
Kingdom Hearts today I'll like I'm
Twitter and some people are talking
about yeah they're excited right so was
it 14 years or something good or 1333
it's one of those things where I'm like
yeah like there are do you think they're
Kingdom Hearts fans can be very
obnoxious at times I had a couple come
after you despite the fact that I'm like
hey I'm also a fan of Kingdom Hearts
like don't you don't need to attack me
but I I do it is nice to see people like
enjoying this game and excited about it
and having a good time a couple of
people saying Kingdom Hearts it's a good
game Kingdom Hearts 3 is a good game and
see Eric you owe John Luke a lunch at a
place and time of his choosing no matter
what you'll have to drop everything and
go yeah that's fine alright
if that like you know helps them sure I
told him the closest thing that I've had
to feeling that way was a long time ago
was it third a second no no I couldn't
secretary there was like fifth or sixth
grade I was playing ff7 and I had got to
final Sephiroth and I was definitely
like way under it like I don't think I
had the tools to fight him but I was
there and somehow I don't know how but
my memory card had lost the save and so
all I could do was use my friends save
but my friend had like knights of the
round he had on the slash he basically
had everything I didn't have where to
spend time into collecting and it made
that fight kind of trivial yeah so so
the only things I hadn't done here and
this isn't really a spoiler is that I
had there's like a series of optional
combat challenges to get okay the game I
did every optional combat challenge
except for the final one which is like a
nut secret boss which is like optional
laughter that's like really hard
probably the hardest boss in the game
and then I hadn't done that and then I
hadn't made the ultimate key bubbly okay
so there's the only couple it's like the
best Keyblade in the game and so I was
like well I can go back and eventually
try and beat that boss maybe I'll make
the Keyblade and then use that to beat
him those are the only two things I had
okay okay sorry
gotta get treasure man sorry's really
love us being a pirate I'm sure we
didn't most people that doesn't look
like anything Bad's gonna happen now
definitely not
sup Bob so John Luke hasn't 100% of it
yeah he's right close I was very close I
was super close I feel like as we talk
about it more and more than chorus I
actually feel I was very close to 100%
of it like that was like all I had left
but I had I had gotten all the I got all
the lucky emblems so that on Thursday
when they put out the secret ending I
could watch it I'm gonna ask you a
question yes and then if it's a spoilery
question just don't answer okay so of
all the preview stuff that we've seen of
like all the worlds and all that stuff
how many would you say like would you
say we've seen most of the world's
already or would you say there's like a
decent amount more that we haven't
actually seen they are no additional
Disney Brooks show there are a couple
like non-disney like Kingdom Hearts
worlds you get at the end that I
honestly think they actually been showed
a little bit of and like a little launch
trailer which is kind of weird honestly
because I feel like you do not want to
show yeah
retro but I know that they've shown all
the Disney roles which I don't know it's
kind of hoping they would like to be
sainted - that was my fear just because
now that we're like mid-to-late ish game
here I was like oh alright well like
we've seen them that's alright my
heart's not in it I know because I broke
your heart
so Huskins this game is challenging to
adults it so it's pretty easy for the
most parts although unless you're
talking unless you're talking and
playing at the same time except for
maybe like at the end it gets a little
tough like some of the final boss stuff
you can get a little tricky
you know how to do those couple times
but if you're playing on standard it's
not too hard it's very much like Kingdom
Hearts 2 so I would if you're looking
for like a challenge I recommend playing
it on crowd mode what are you on right
now I'm asking
it's over
yeah I think I think hard hard core
Kingdom Hearts fans are like really get
really into the combat stuff had oh
you're alive no problem
they're gonna want to play on probably's
literally on around my pixel health now
he was Adam oh and
the treasure get that treasure what it's
still good see you later
or not Oh where's Jar Jar mmm
who knows Kingdom Hearts poor dude like
20 years from now I don't know when
they're gonna make another one I would
really like them to make so gonna make
more of these obviously they've said
that that's insane to me like it's just
like not that they're gonna keep making
them but that seems pretty normal but
like who knows how long that's gonna
take
sure I mean the thing is that it's weird
because they it's not like they've been
working on this for 13 years they didn't
start making it until like 2014 they've
only been working on it for like 40 it's
just been 13 years as well yeah because
they've been making all those spin-offs
and stuff yeah mobile games if you will
not like when I call them spin-offs even
though they are by definition it's cut
off but whatever fight me
fit off doesn't mean it's not important
it just means the spin-off anyway yeah
they've liked this this game has
actually had a very normal like dead
Siamese for the most for the most part
like it is not like I think people are
under the impression like they've been
making it for 13 years like not really
it looks good though it looks good and
well that's the thing is if they make it
more when they make more Kingdom Hearts
I would prefer they just make them on
consoles specifically because I'm like
this engine looks like it runs on unreal
before this looks really really nice and
I really love just like how good it
looks and I'm like man like like the
detail like even when yeah we saw Jack
Sparrow I think like that that was like
pretty cool just make them make them on
this system that looks really good huh
of course Jack Finders Keepers Jack
Sparrow sound alike is just pretty
decent there's a couple times where
you're like but like the most part it's
pretty good
bus like what you can mate now then my
ship has a captain but it does appear
I'm in need of a crew love from India's
infinity - I'm old
it's weird how realistic this like
uncanny valley this pirates world looks
and like you look at Sora and like
Donald goofy and they give him like
realistic like texture and stuff that
you don't get on the other world so it's
like so it looks like he belongs in jump
force yeah good quality bottom where
it's like a big dopey anime eyes but
then realistic like skin texture with
Wars and you're like ah that looks real
weird those hand wrinkles yeah
dude I would honestly love like I know
they've kind of they'd be like kept
porting them but if they like remade
like one and two in like this engine I
would don't give them ideas I would
don't play that I'm hey give them no
money man I'm all for that
this engine looks beautiful Essaouira
has the elite of battle angel syndrome
didn't bail yes Sydney shrimp though
that's another one way bigger I think
and then they shrunk him a little bit
cuz everyone was like holy crap her eyes
are like way too big just really weird
though cuz swords like again he's got
the anime eyes and then you're next to
Jack Sparrow who's like yeah candy
Valley level of uh alright so we got the
ship here this is kind of what makes
this yes this year old unique is that
sees you you get like a ship is like
ship combat and I don't have this like
oh very grin it's small but it is an
open world where you can like go to
different islands and
so we're playing black flag we're
playing we're playing black flag we're
playing some AC but like yeah you got
all these islands you can explore it's
not as big as you think like you look at
this and you're like wow that's huge
it's actually like like you get to him
pretty quickly yeah like that right
there
yeah is that little of laments it's a
smaller map than you maybe at first I
was like holy crap this is huge but it's
really not but by Kingdom Hearts
standards it's pretty big and it's cool
like I I I think it is a nice different
it's a nice difference for sure ready
my guy I enjoy that stuff this might be
a spoiler stuff and if it is I'm gonna
should I cut away no no I'll just I'll
just pause it I'm just trying to
remember it's okay it's gonna be all
right Donald
yeah that's story stuff for skipping it
let's get that Azzam again here's a
here's a dumb question I've asked for a
long time a long time about Donald oh
yeah all right clearly the man doesn't
wear pants yeah the duck doesn't wear
pants yeah but when he comes out of the
shower he always has a towel around as
well that's a good point why uh to dry
himself
yeah but why does heat why would he have
a towel around his waist
oh why specifically right yeah wait why
around his waist I'm gonna why around
the waist specifically but nothing he's
covering up he basically commando-style
right now anyways that's a good question
I mean I assumed we would just be trying
to dry himself here's another fun fact
right like with with with and we'll if
and when you know Kingdom Hearts pour
right Sheriff even though it's Kingdom
Hearts to be a hunch tape talking about
Kmart's for hey man that's like the
whole thing you'd beat a game near me
like yeah someone's the next one yeah
come on square the crazy thing is how
much is me like how much properties and
things they own
it's actually like um like I feel like
it's a monopoly oh it is it's it's
actually pretty gross they're in tourism
how how is no way stop them there is a
IGN twe and this is not me right I
shouldn't I've seen I've seen the one
the movie tweet that where they were
like here's all the big mistake coming
out these newbies or Jerry or all invite
is knee yeah and it's like just the
reality of the situation like that's
terrifying yeah I mean I did it's partly
why I brought it up is that that tweet I
saw I was like holy crap I did not even
think about that and I'm like looking at
them all and I'm like that is actually
all Disney yeah so you got to imagine
like some type of Star Wars right at
some point well so apparently I don't
know if like Nomura was really seriously
wanted it but apparently like Marvel and
Star Wars are under different light news
departments of Disney so like that would
it was apparently they had to like but
it wasn't like they could just go
through their usual channels to get it
they had to like talk to those specific
Department so it's not that they
couldn't do it I think it's with Kingdom
Hearts 3 they were like that is a lot
more work than maybe is worth us doing
for 3 right now maybe if they go at it
again exactly if they maybe from the
get-go the beginning of development go
in specifically right right
we know how well that worked out yeah
couple those figuring I like the figure
games they actually cry makes it brings
up a good point yeah Disney owns more
than 50% of entertainment news and
sports and they're gonna start streaming
soon yeah it's a lot man
defense Oh God Oh first part thanks Sora
oh wow what is that my super tact that
seems pretty good oh nice
ramming speed hi that's cool I don't
yeah I don't mind that I'm in it um a
Murcia asking how you guys like him game
I actually haven't played it I like it I
like it quite a bit
I mean it's a really fun game I like the
combat like the world like the world
characters yeah I enjoyed the story for
how much weight and just as like a
reference point you are a king hearts
fan though right I would consider myself
a fan of Kingdom Hearts I don't know if
I am a Kingdom Hearts fan in the way
think of okay he's think of y ou are
Khorkina Mart's fan like I'm certainly
not one of those people I'm but I I do
like Kingdom Hearts yeah I also fully
acknowledge all of its [ __ ] I'm just
like yeah I know this is [ __ ] I know
this is dumb and convoluted and but I I
enjoy I've had been isn't around cuz he
dislikes Kingdom Hearts and watch he's
actually gonna play he's got to play
three no he's a he's just got a bad he
like threw out his back the other day so
he's recovering from that and like I
said he could have helped Bend this is
on you you could have helped me save
John Luke today I'm just getting bad I'm
just trying to find someone else's the
bus here but yeah
alexa level fan of kingdom hearts that's
a throwback see I know she's excited
about the game sure I'm more like a like
a Lucy like talking with Lucy I feel
like we have 30 similar opinions it's
what we were like you know grew up
playing um big fan of you know the
nostalgia and enjoy it but also our like
crazy so this is a little a little bad
in a bit much
I'll say my problem with three it's
three story it's not necessarily because
it's it's super fanservice see like in
its story and I don't I don't actually
mind that like they go real hard on the
fanservice again I think Kingdom Hearts
fans will be like actually pretty happy
with it but it's not pretty
I think that story like does get you
away like kind of like the the larger
story they're trying to tell like the
fanservice almost is a little bit of a
detriment to the narrative they're
trying to tell us in a way that I never
felt like to was I thought to had like a
good or a better balance good yeah but
but again I think if you are a hardcore
fan who very much cares about those
fanservice II moments I think you'll be
happy without me gonna be disappointed
oh come on Jack Sparrow do something
negotiate your way out of this one and I
stopped watching Pirates of the
Caribbean I don't even know what number
is on I think it's like the first three
and I stood up I watched the first three
they've made five of them they made two
of them that I never apparently those
last you were very bad just like that no
one cared there's that infamous like
story where apparently like Johnny Depp
patches like lines that threw him
through your piece oh really like the
fifth line I love that first movie I
mean it's still a great movie
yeah the first first one was good okay
fine third one's too long way too long
but there's like three hours it's like
really it's really like the Lord of the
Rings yeah like they were trying to go
real hard on it in a way that I would
display this is too much worlds and
that's why they have to let go that's
the one that this um this is based on
okay Kingdom Hearts 3 is based on wealth
oh is that the one with traveling fat
yes okay yeah that one was like that
early in it and then Keira Knightley
becomes the captain at that point
becomes the the head of all the Pirates
she runs like the pirate queen
oh that's cool oh that's the monster
Zinka all right what are we pairing
oh he's Captain America so what's your I
saw a tweet this morning about like I
think it was like specifically I
wouldn't say targeting less but like it
was like a tweet about like us reporting
on game lengths and like and like making
a favor no wait not you know I'm saying
like there was a tweet that was I think
it pertained to us telling people how
long it took to beat like Kingdom Hearts
like game wait
yeah that might Mike made a response to
okay yeah so I I didn't I was just asked
gonna ask you your thoughts on it
because I'm at this school of kind of
like how Cali responded to which was
that I think it's like a service kind of
thing to like know how long game is I
don't think it necessarily like it's
like a measurement of how good or bad a
game is it's just more of like a like
how long a movie is I think is what
Callie said and like just like knowing
like oh it could take like that long I
never thought of it as like us like
measuring or judging yeah yeah I'm time
and I thought I was like oh I don't see
why that's such a big deal but I was
like curious if you saw the same way or
thought like well I definitely do in
general things that I do get disappoint
when I see people put the the worth of a
game based on time in that like oh this
games only three hours three hours
versus this game is you know 50 hours so
obviously it's better even though in a
lot of cases I would argue like well hey
I think you know Resident Evil 2 it'll
only take it takes you like five hours
to beat like yeah right so like you can
beat that game and see you like most of
its content in like 10 hours right and
versus like oh I played 60 hours of a
scene
but I would argue like I enjoyed all ten
of those hours exact like how much of
the actual hours that I find tedious so
I always think that argument is kind of
like we can blame but I don't think
there's anything wrong with me knowing
how long it is and in our art we was not
judgemental it was literally just yeah
because dude that is it I think that is
something worth knowing because like you
know you're someone who's but there's
nothing I don't think the same thing
wrong we see knowing how long yeah
people need to know that like hey this
how long can take you to beat this I can
only play this many hour yeah
I mean I just think about how long like
a read that could be technically like
you know I mean if you yeah it's really
wide we're gonna be investing in like
doesn't give you full health huh
what oh no no no it did I just lost him
oh um cuz like I used so many of those
kind of mechanics even like God of War
like rage like going in a rage was just
like to get my life back the rage form
is just there to get you uh because even
in anthem demo just last weekend I was
really using the Ultimates just to get
my life back
yeah well Ben's here what's up in you
haven't heard me blaming you this whole
time until now oh here we go fine it's
nice to see a team attack with Captain
Jack Sparrow they made me think of the
Lonely Island guys song with Michael on
the microphone
oh hey did that actually hit him
no humping sorry yeah I was like that
looks really cool but it's one of those
attacks it's like this is better in the
group yeah bad everyone's sending you
love I have to say the graphics look
amazing so she said where they are they
really are incredible looking especially
when you get to go to like the frozen
stuff where you're like damn looks like
I'm watching the movie like that like
that would be cool just to like play in
that world with like some of my like
nieces that love frozen because they
probably like oh my god it's I get to
hang out with them and yeah quiz kill
says Briggs nope I think Witcher 3 is a
perfect example of a game that's long
what everything is meaningful can be
longer if you do all the side missions
but everything still feels good yep just
kind of like going on your point oh yeah
like I'm perfectly fine with a hundred
hour game it's like I feels like most of
those hours are meaningful there might
have only been that white loading team
because we skipped a cutscene so the
screens oh yeah that's cuz I am just go
set a couple like weird they're kind of
loading in a little bit you want to talk
about loading screen anthems anyways
back to Kingdom Hearts 3 right well this
is unfortunately one of the worst parts
of the game they make all this weird
like crab hun and yeah yeah yeah crab
hunt you just have to wander around Port
Royale which is immediately very huge
and you just gotta collect crabs also
I'm not East it like I have like the
glide so I'm just like not used to
having all these abilities I don't have
to tricks
yeah alright entertain the crowd
entertain the crowd what's up Robert
Shaw there's your shoutout I hope this
game comes with PCs as idv 12th Unreal
Engine 4 a lot of people really really
want Kingdom Hearts on switch at least
on like the older ones
which back to your remaster yeah or
remake I read you can definitely do the
remaster they've already done this
oh that I guess that's true so now do
you see I'm talking like a proper engine
like remake these game those games in
this engine because this is probably
like also this is the area where the
framerate drops the most because it's
just the most dense and like the
realistic tech like the the more
detailed textures versus the other world
so if you see the frame rate dropping
just know that this is sort of like the
area where it does set also one thing I
really like a lot about compared to you
- - is this we're like fairly empty oh
my god you have to get 300 crap sorry
yes we're now understand well saying I I
didn't think it'd be 300 anyways start
continue the worlds and the other ones
were pretty empty were like they'd be
like Oh like talking about you know like
oh I do this for the people and then
there's like there's no one there
right like an Agrabah or whatever right
but in these areas like they actually
have like there's people walking around
like look at that so get out of my way
it takes advantage of the next
generation Jay I'll hide the in the
crowd avoid the Templars Ben says I went
to go start this last night but I felt
really guilty like I didn't deserve to
play it yet do you watch all the story
catch-up cutscenes I don't know they
they they added some like videos you
watch oh yeah I mean either you are Matt
tweeting about it or which is good
because when I played it before they'd
have any of that and I was like dang
that seems weird because they don't
explain anything and you just gonna have
to know what's going on figure it out
chote Eddie says beautiful games like
this are dying because a fortnight nice
kill in the game industry now I don't I
don't think the people that would play
for tonight would be playing this game
anyways for the most part I wouldn't say
like everyone but I would just say that
the majority of that demographic I don't
imagine would be playing this way now
would that does that mean that they
wouldn't play it if porn I didn't exist
or that it would play worthy oh you're
using them my dad twin yo yo I like this
that's any time I don't know any time
people are like awkward and it's gonna
be a mystery this is that it's like
everyone said that about you know
everyone said that about like the weed
around so that about mobile games and
Angry Birds and I'm like dude it's just
like it's just a bad it like it's just
another one of those games at all any
time people decry that I'm like dude
like people have said that about
everything it's people things will be
fine just like MOBAs are rounds I mean
League and dota still exist but you know
that whole mo bookbag outside of like
those two games and maybe like I have a
small handful of others like don't
really they're not there anymore
it's just
I can certainly understand being tired
of of for tonight that's absolutely
understandable I would say I am but I at
this point I don't ever get cry as like
the death of video games because it's
like don't get one saying that about
games for years and those games always
like do people still remember Angry
Birds I think that was yeah I mean like
think about that movie that came out
like kind of too late yeah like it was
definitely trying to ride the momentum
of like all the people playing Angry
Birds but that movie was like at least a
year too late because all that momentum
had died off that always happens like I
remember them being like there was like
talks about like oh we're gonna make a
five nights at Freddy's movie and I'm
like dude like mmm that's gonna be like
even I'd one I doubt they're still
making that and even if they are it's
like well you're way too late now two
years too late we're part not gonna tell
you the number of worlds just because
that's spoilery sure oh I just not say
si priyo em says I won't play this but
I'm just amazed by how big of a game
this is yeah it's um there's a lot of
content there it took so it took two
more about 24 hours he said to beat it
it took me twenty six look I did all
faster than in but then me going back in
like getting all the collectible stuff
took me like an additional hours do they
do like a new game first there is no new
game okay lost that I'm away the crabs
holy smokes
that's why this is by far the most
tedious part okay it's a game in my
opinion it's weird it's weird that they
put this part in like I'm just like the
teaching you about cuz you you can
collect crabs upgrade your ship for some
reason like the crabs like fix your ship
magical crab but the kind you want
I don't know why they make you collect
three someone subscribes do a lot
should've been 100 I have the trees
right under it
what is that white glow wave on all the
buildings too late now oh that means you
can run up them when that's on a wall
that signifies what you can I found some
crabs yeah I mean Carmine's a good point
too I mean we have a bunch of big story
games especially like last year got a
war Spider Man O'War spider-man Yakuza
Monster Hunter world although I don't
know how much of a story game monster
world is but that was a that was a long
game though I enjoyed this that game
story for what it is but I you know what
we got
Metro coming out we got a lot 415 so
yeah Metro you have crackdown you have
technically anthem early access or far
cry new dawn jump horse I think in the
50 of course hey man Death Note is just
story you know you're gonna have that's
an interesting one
I don't think that game was very to me
but that's but I'm just not into those
country yeah I wish like it was just he
could have just cel-shaded it and called
it a day but they got that like look
that you're talking about earlier where
they kind of just like I like love hate
it I'm like I love that they went that
far to do that but I kind of hate yeah
I'm kind of like in that weird place
that you're in which is like it's kind
of cool but then it's kind of like weird
yeah I don't know the comic just when I
played it granted I only played a little
bit it's just my heel as crisp as I
wanted it to be I don't know she's never
my kind of like those third persons
really good in third person and I just
don't think about like this would like
because like for me like I keep thinking
about that game and then I I'm like man
like what jump horse was like that and I
wish some man was I wish what not one
people my hero was like that and then my
hero doesn't even feel that good as a
fighting game it's like I mean looks
like fine and it's just like super
fanservice II did you you see the
trailer
teasing the new new Dragon Ball game I
still okay isn't that is that not the
card game I don't think so okay cuz
there's there's there's gonna be a game
that's like the card game right now yeah
and then I was like here hold on let me
see
but uh it's it's weird how much like
fighters is like kind of ruin to me
we're like I saw that and I was like wow
that's all shading doesn't like as good
as fighters like you know what I mean
yeah I felt bad I'm like oh they
probably worked really hard on this but
I'm sitting feeling better project G
okay yeah I can finally emblems because
guess what I know where they all are
oh yeah there's one right here
oh those emblems the Mickey emblems
that's what I spent all yesterday
getting will get them again right now
I can tell you where they all are I have
the mostly memorize at this point
get me some classic Mickey yeah I found
the class do you have to like go to like
well guessing multiple worlds then yeah
there are there they're hidden around
they're hidden around all the world
didn't you say like your your teammates
will kind of tell you like oh hey I
think they do not every time every time
it sometimes they do look at all those
crabs yeah and we'd be rich if we had a
crab place like a crab shack or industry
selling crabs crabs aren't cheap and you
can't like when you like when you catch
crab here you can only have so many a
thing
some like that you can only catch so
many facets what's an action-rpg yeah
but I there was no gameplay right it was
almost like a like hey you want to
relive some of these moments huh
which I was like oh you mean literally
every dragon ball game ever I mean
they're like the saga every dragon ball
game every target ball game is just bad
but but xenoverse is technically
classified as a action RPG right yeah
okay this is also called an RPG or like
oh yeah I'm like yeah exactly Xenoblade
essentially that like okay Jenna Molina
verse 3 for all we know but they're not
calling it that projects project Z but
that could just be the like the the fake
name you know kind of like how shadows
died twice with the thing and then it
turns out a sick hero right securitrons
my place yeah but what was it before
what did we think it was before
what do you mean like you know what we
first saw that one teaser trailer yeah
uh was at e3 yeah we didn't know the
name of the game it was twice because
that was the little little blur but that
was a blurb at the end so everyone just
referred to it as shadows died twice and
then it turns out oh it's suck your own
shadow side twice
I wasn't expecting this outside place to
actually be a part of the name but yeah
I was like oh man just give me that
season two fighters
yeah well it's out or it's gonna be this
Thursday we're gonna probably play
girion and Vidal how they put fidelity
yeah oh that's cool and then what's
awesome is like kind of like her partner
the same way like 16 centers is 16 17
work yeah where what's his name Sandman
basic no is that right yeah which is
Gohan basically right yes you remember
because my superhero like saying hey so
he is like her that's pretty good I like
that
does that mean we're gonna get miss be
safe I don't know I know everyone's like
always a joke character yeah I love them
too but like if they were gonna bring
him in I'd want him in that kind of
capacity where he's just someone you
call in kind of like the ginyu force you
know it's another Mickey you don't like
oh that's kind of yeah I see it
ya know they do a lot of these there's
like the ones I I caught earlier where
it's he's benched in and then there's a
lot of like if you look at this rock
formation it creates a a Mickey Mouse
and they're like okay I mean I've gone
to Disneyland and I've never found be
like hated Mickey's we kind of look
every now and then when I go with my
fiance but like I'm like I don't see it
wanting like Indiana Jones and I'm like
uh what I know I like Tareen the leg
like while you're in the line why why is
it aligned for Indiana Jones they're
supposed to be a hit and Mickey like
somewhere like if you look back a
certain way you see a Hidden Mickey or
yeah I bet
can't you say I love that they've never
changed the Indiana Jones show I'm like
because I saw that as a kid I was like
fire or something oh I thought was the
coolest thing and then I went back there
like a couple years ago
and it's the same show and I was like
that's great maybe cheated at all fun
fan love that if you go to the Tokyo
Disney one it's it's it's slightly
different
oh what's different about it I
can't exactly remember but there is like
is it cuz of the whole world war two
like they kind of change I don't recall
exactly what it was but there there are
subtle differences compared to the like
us oh you're just all over any of those
you need so if you want to it depends I
don't know if you want what you said you
were secret if you want the secret
ending it depends if you are playing on
the easiest difficulty you have to
collect them all except the whole thing
if you're playing on standard you have
to collect less on the roof and if you
are playing on proud mode you only have
to collect a few okay I don't know the
exact number like that has not been like
yeah a field yet but had it so how did
you know you were gonna have enough then
oh they're even I'm okay I just got them
all oh I just wanted them all okay there
would be no doubt there'd be no doubt
it's like I'm definitely gonna get this
ending because I just collected all of
them yeah oh we're so close oh yeah
alright I've been I've been on a tangent
with you let me check chat here seven
more crap now we got all the crabs now
yep we're good there's 17 18 my bed and
then 19 is the the other guy yeah man I
honestly like even as a kid didn't
really watch past like cells no freeze I
saw go
I just couldn't do it anymore I I
couldn't do it I couldn't wait two more
episodes as Gohan Goku is literally
holding his GD Spirit Bomb and having a
conversation with Frieza and he's like
freeze up like I it's no problem just
keep doing that I don't I don't I can
deal with it and and we'll just have a
long conversation
whoo is that almost like was it 15 the
stupid goddamn it it's 15 right where he
teleports we would knocked his telephone
yeah yeah we're that always be they came
too hard sting my god this is that's the
shock foot stuff has been our Chocolat
stuff was added in birth by asleep and
then the the jumping thing is sort of
like this one like the mobility stuff
which is a relatively new thing for
knives here's another one also it told
me I had 16 and I was like there's like
75 there's 75 there's a lot there's like
there's a lot you don't need alright
there's a lot ohso you've gotten a
decent amount no the the numbers me the
red means I haven't got him oh snap yeah
again if you didn't miss the beginning
of the stream I kind of got gently to
override it and was farther in the game
but here he basically committed seppuku
and was like I'll just get rid of my
save I don't need it I don't want to see
the secret ending I'll look it up I'm
gonna just watch it when someone will
put it up online immediately and I'm
gonna watch it that's fair mmm you need
to skip this are we good weekend
although I kind of want you funnel back
this cuz he's real weird
okay that's fine anything what makes
show this cutscene cuz I just want you
to see how weird it is is there any
particular reason we wanted this ship
and he looks so good
yes it's good looking good looking at
yeah to explore the Seas free is the
wind good answer
you are a pirate captain Sora
but Jack why do you keep saying final
like you're leaving yeah yes because
this me has run his course mate he was
the Krabs all along you I the surrogates
me that the goddess of the sea sent here
to help you lot well of course
enemies still me oh maybe duplicatable
but I'm always incomparable the sea she
smiles upon a surah let's leave it at
that shall we
for now the real me has a crucial
engagement at shipwreck Cove where the
pirate brethren will meet Beckett in its
lot and battle to win back our freedom
then let us help
no it's for pirates to resolve but not
you Sora yours free is the wins now and
far you go
crabs baby honey just explode into a
pile of crabs we could have had 300
crabs right there anyway I watched that
cutscene and I was like what it's
happening slowly Jack spur was really a
pile of crabs what magical crap magical
crabs anyway so I was right that's a
that's a cutscene Happ that happens in
the game I remember I was like what
Aquarius there is no timestamp of when
he overrode the save cuz it was before
we even got on the street yeah I'll try
that thing that you sent I don't know I
don't I think it's too late for that
yeah I feel like like look out weirdly
realistic it's so weird
it looks good but you're also like
goddamn like this stuff is like weird
pretty good yeah God
alright let's get back you just wanted
to watch him walk up I just wanted I
just wanted to show the reshape the
detail I mean that's not really spoilers
for the game that's just for us for
pipes like am i keep Kumar says hey mate
what do you think about Sakura I haven't
played it you played like what a little
bit now I was going to but I didn't get
a go I was like I had to do something
else that sucks I'm looking forward to
it but you said he owed me something for
that and so maybe maybe it's like I oh
yeah I'm just like people list me I'm
excited though I okay
on a personal level I am cautiously
excited only because I've never been one
for stealth games and that is heavily
what sec ero is supposed to be yeah it's
a South actions death action stealth but
I'm curious to see kind of like a slight
tweak or change in some of the formula
although it's kind of like tenth us I
guess is is kind of like right mm-hmm
so I don't know there's so many games
that I have to think and worry about
before SEC ero so but I'm looking
forward to it it's a tandem
I think it's March 22nd yeah not stealth
like you think Eric well kind of
it's got stuff elements but it's not I
think you could still play it fairly on
stealth if you want
okay so I could just yolo swaggins yeah
you probably could all right
Ben says I'm very excited for SEC euro
cuz your boy loves Tenchu I like to see
a new tent you well just play second row
because that's as close as you're gonna
get for good
I was only going to be ten true yeah and
even like the apparently even though you
like shadows died twice line is in a 10
shoe game yeah apparently that doesn't
like mine like a boss like a boss says
yeah I went down the real deep rabbit
hole trying to figure out what it was oh
man I there's no way it's blood-borne
but do you think they'll eventually do a
blood-borne 2 because people still
really
walk that well there were those hints
there subtle hints in the the VR game
with the doll yeah all kind of made it
seem like the story was kind of not
finished somebody from from software
said like oh no those are just Easter
eggs they don't need anyone like you
would say that I don't know that game
was so good like I would I would
definitely play another one I don't know
if like maybe they are making like we
have another game yeah they have like
two games right that like is it two
games that they they have been announced
or something like that one would
presumably be their armored Corps game
they've been trying to work on but what
is that is that the case that like is
that is did I understand that it that
headline right like that they took of
the two games like we know what they are
or were they like completely let me look
that up I think they didn't say what
they are but we know that they're
working on an armored car game yeah yeah
because he took he took off to kind of
like almost like took a break from like
you know the Souls II games to go do
something different
well not different because they've done
you know I'm record before but
let's see this from gamespot blood borne
to speculation begin damn you Jordan
while it isn't time to discuss the
details they're both from some they are
both from software ESCA games the
thought he said
fire I call winds
and metal K a metal wolf chaos XD is not
the art that's like separate from the
armored core thing right
Oh too soon oh oh if that's just a
rerelease of it yeah okay software game
yeah I don't know this article doesn't
actually dive into the fact that if
they're to like that we don't know about
or if they count like if it counts the
arm with core again because we know
about that one we just haven't seen
anything from it fence is a plan to
rearrange parts of the Caribbean theme
song yep all these games do that it's
anybody like we're the worth point in
this this world where you knew how to
just like to run around and like check
out the different like islands nice find
your you're hitting emblems and all that
good stuff I can't I can't do my like my
glide sucks it's how you get and that's
how you get around
oh is that something you get a little
bit later on you get that in the next
world it's it's from the other games as
well we're like basically you can just
like fly around infinitely and it's
really good for getting around real
quick when you're looking for emblem
looking for them hot emblems well stay
tuned to John Luke's video of all 75
actually I mean hey I [ __ ] it all I
recorded it I'll probably see that
reminds me of the wiggly monster phone
wants to hunt the same thing over the
camping yeah
did you see the Hat thing is it happen
you can buy the wiggly wants your hat or
something oh like a real version yeah
yeah
think we'll
[Music]
yeah y'all remember when friend
software's making our record games they
came a long way yeah well they're making
a new one right so Aquarius excited for
Metro access and EMC 5 I think there's a
few games I found who also like my tribe
I really like those first two games
lupa says love warned - exclamation
marks would feel like that would be very
nice I can't believe it's a frozen -
they're gonna make so much money
crime thinks blood-borne - for ps5
really think I mean like other than
first from Sony's perspective as a
console seller right potential console
seller they're gonna need stuff for
related is you'll get new crops soon I
feel pretty confident we're gonna make
me start hearing about him this year
okay it might come out next year
sure sort of yeah yeah hey I can uh I if
I were to bet or something like that and
like you told me like you know here are
the years that you could predict
potentially that it will come out I
would agree with you that that we're
pretty close but not definitely not this
year but probably you know some type of
you know either
score you know like project Scorpio time
you know right yeah I agree with you I
would just wonder like I don't know like
blood-borne it wasn't it wasn't the type
of game that really took advantage of
even the pro right well that's because
it came out that's a freaking yeah okay
get up before the pro and it was long
enough before the pro that they never
had it in like there were a couple games
that came out right before the pro like
uncharted that they added like pro
support back into but in blood-borne was
far enough that they never did that do
you feel like I wish they did real bad
okay so you think that it would enhance
it well I guess it probably would raise
yeah the frame rates pretty sometimes at
OSHA it's like alright dude even like a
ps5 like we just rerelease blood-borne
to run on the PS 5 or whatever and stop
giving them terrible ideas it's a good
idea but you know they did it with a lot
of us 1 they're gonna do it will last it
was - you know they are yeah there's
gonna be a different version of PS 5
room
- is going to be the exact same such
situations last to us well I think it's
gonna be like the swan song game for the
ps4 and then they're gonna what if that
would be a ps5 but well saying is that
since we're at this point where we're
gonna start hearing about new consoles
what do you think is left for exclusives
for like both PlayStation and Xbox
before yeah for the PlayStation 4 and
for Xbox one like what do they have left
I mean there's Last of Us yeah and then
I think there's like crackdown
that's clearly like next month like like
all are this month like I feel like I
know all the big stuff that Xbox like
you know all the outside of Gears 5 I
think yours 5 is maybe the last big
thing on the Xbox one because I feel
like leather ports maybe another 4 do
you think that just wait I don't know
because I feel like all of those studios
that they bought it they're definitely
making games for the Xbox yeah they're
not making games for and and we would
have to imagine halo 6 or whatever
infinite would all infinite sorry would
would probably be next next I think
whatever the next early that game sounds
like it's in well we never really saw
anything other than like it was like the
tech demo right right what what they
talked about interviews it and sounded
like the game still very early in
development so I'm thinking that it's
not gonna be on Xbox but like Sony like
they had a really good year last year
right with like God of War and
spider-man and all this stuff but I
don't think like there's gonna be a God
of War - there's gonna be a Spider Man -
I don't think those games are gonna come
out on the current consoles
yeah I'm trying to think what else is
left even for like what do you what do
you think about neo - well that's coming
out that's and development um you think
you think you know but I make it before
I think it'll make it before it's also
like not really mix yes the first one
was but I don't think it will be but
like in the same like you're talking
like really big that's probably like a
like kind of screaming so he's always
had the unfair advantage where all of
the Japanese like devs it's some of the
really big ones obviously make their
games I got killed
we were talking we're talking and I went
to an area that I was probably like not
before but um like all of those devs
make games just for the PlayStation
because no one has Xboxes in Japan so
sort so any like just by virtue of being
a Japanese like like console developer
it kind of has the advantage over Xbox
where they just naturally get like free
exclusives right yeah things like sec
you're out things like Yakuza right like
they're all these like games that are
just like yet we just kind of make them
for the PlayStation only because then
we're not gonna bother an Xbox version
because we make these primarily for like
out the Japanese audience they kind of
have that weird advantage that I like I
feel bad for Microsoft because it's like
as we're talking about it earlier I was
just like man it's so weird to see this
on an Xbox like k3 it really is
sure but I like that's kind of the
exception to the rule because it's like
square yeah they didn't make that
transition but still it's just like yeah
even then before like
they didn't put out the recollections on
here so it's like this if you want to
play the over games and still have to
all the way on a Playstation it's weird
it's rough yeah I'm getting I'm getting
beat up real hard never really had this
happen I think because it's just having
a deeper story yet but you're not
supposed to be here maybe maybe they
want you to do all this stuff after 368
online says do you think this game will
be a goatee contender me never know like
now super early in the year I've only
played two games with both games I've
played I would put in my top ten but the
only two games I've played this year
remake right yeah remaking them but
that's uh that's a weird thing because
it's like I don't know those are the
only two games I play so it's like easy
to say that yeah I mean do you think I
I'm trying to think like if we would
even do you want to like do you think
remake would count peyote I think it
does okay I think I will make that
argument when because I think that will
be a case to be made but I think that
game is so fundamentally different
playing than the original that it it is
in the many ways its own game yeah it
would be a disservice to do not count it
as like worthy enough of being a
contender
because it it's so like saying like oh
like putting in the same category is
like like a port it's like such a
disservice to it I think anyway I think
it's a lot of chatter I think it can I
think it so that is a debate will have
okay go kill oh basically says love one
with loose bones has bare frame thank
you that's what that it does it is
better it is undoubtedly better but it's
it's not taking advantage
of the pros hardware the way it could
with like a proper pro patch but yeah
you're ready it is better and that is
definitely like I went there many people
did that shot yeah Xbox does now own the
developers that made cinemas hell-blade
John's last of us to for ps5 launch I
don't think so I think it'll be more
likely that what John Luke I mentioned
earlier will happen which is you'll get
ps4 hopefully week right like what you
speculate maybe this year right for all
of us to or you think no I bet early
next year ok sound like this alright
either way before PS 5 though right and
then it'll would like have like a PS 5
version because I don't think the PS 5
will come out until you think past 2020
I think the PS 5 would come out past
2020 I think it would come out or no no
sorry it'll come on 2020 I think it'll
come out in there 20 points like end of
2020 or like mid mid or end of 2021 yeah
no 2020 ok 2020 ok so next year in the
fall I think just moving to get the PS 5
and I think we'll get last of us to in
like your April the way last of us 1/2
because last of us 1 if you remember
came out like the week before e3 right I
mean I didn't work in games is the ship
battle better than sea of thieves now I
like yeah I think didn't see if things
get a bunch of like updates like I did
we don't have me I don't have a swamp
monster dicks marker yeah but apparently
uh people are into that game now it's a
it's more comparable to like an
assassin's creed I'd still say like
Assassin's Creed house like that better
boat feel where like you play this and
it feels like weirdly like our Katie and
floaty where you're like oh this ship
just kind of turns it doesn't have like
a late
they put a lot of ooh somebody tried to
login or something over during the other
stream - but it's weird cuz like I don't
know anyone who would use my uh someone
in the speed zone maybe maybe can also
be my parents trying to log in to watch
a movie they haven't they have an Xbox
at home and I think that's my account on
it that's another good one ditched
random do you think that that's just
gonna be like a spy that's and yet they
until psy that is definitely a ps5 game
I can guarantee oh man oh yeah the game
no stop it she was doing that I'm about
to peek outside and like look to see if
somebody's like literally I honestly bet
you it's my parents like oh we should
watch some Netflix because they probably
normally don't have that problem because
I xbox crime things both ps4 and PS 5 4
- Brandon and I like are like Last of Us
argument I can see it coming up on ps4
as like a but I don't think it old I
don't think that game will come out
until PS 5 is for sure
give him even give kijima even more time
well be eating toenails by then or
ripping toenails that was like a real
crunchy moment I remember during that
trailer
yeah riff is like Tony Olaf I think but
there's a lot of weirdness going on in
that guy that trailer
oh yeah cyberpunk - I don't think that's
gonna be this you think next gen dude
yeah look you look out I'm like that
game will not run on these consoles that
well you think so okay there's no way
that game just goes PC first and then
console later right no I don't think
they would you would be like oh it'd be
like all three or nothing I think it'd
be all three or nothing I think it's
gonna be next-gen and I don't know if
the time it would work out but I bet it
would be real great if it was a launch
game for those systems like like you
bought you buy your new system and
you're like cuz that's the thing you
always buy a new console and you're like
you need a yeah what was it nothing on
it
right that was that was the that was my
ps3 mistake that's a hundred percent
that was my ps4 mistake as well let's go
like Harburg tech demo thing yeah and I
mean I made the same argument with
breadth of the while I was like dude
they're gonna wait I'm like you want a
game to sell for that you wanted the
switch to sell you you you keep breath
of the wild yeah exactly as a launch
title I'm like I mean I bought a switch
for breath of the wild hell if it if
they can get the timing where it's done
I bet you they'd be like launch game for
the PS 5 Xbox to whatever they're gonna
call it and then that is you're like big
that's your big like oh man you gotta
get like even if they don't have like
you know a big exclusive it's like dude
you've got to get the PS 5 like you can
play cyberpunk on it
like that's that's the game that
convinces people to buy a new system
cyberpunk can you match up like say like
Red Dead - was like a launch game for
like a new system that party
yeah so I think I say that game is sold
like crazy well I think it's I think a
same thing that's due to like big like
this gets people to buy your new sister
system sellers right it's just him
selling them hikiko commie says why
would - Brandon come out on PS 5 Kojima
doesn't want another phantom pain
phantom pain good well that was it your
blood board came out to you though I
remember I was left before and we're
like yeah we got it - 4 Mike Tam we did
it and then it's like [ __ ] we could have
got a higher I think yeah lotta game
that was a richer year was your years
long
rocket League yep rocket League battle
geared
oh man undertale no one was probably
fight in front or tail then you didn't
have mean Callie and Michael in a very
different conversation
I would also voted upon
that was like my day over here like
looking back on it I'm like that's the
game I remember mostly The Witcher Wall
was like impenetrable
I feel like pretty much yeah overwatch
breath of the wild red red dead for the
most part that's kind of it was a little
easier this year though yeah in terms of
like yeah just our process Oh Teddy I
have not played Maximo you okay last
elgu what were those yo yo what's this
game all about oh you gotta watch the
history of so watch the history of
Kingdom Hearts John Luke
Lucy and Richard put in some fine work
we'll get you caught up so yeah
send me over goofball
yeah and if you guys didn't know we
livestream Monday to Friday 11:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time we'll be back
tomorrow when hopefully Ben's back doing
some Monster Hunter because there's a
big anniversary for the game as that
girl tells also unlike a week or two
oh is it yeah I need to put that into
the dock that's like early February and
what are we doing Thursday like I said
Dragon Ball fighters checking out the
DLC some cheering you gotta think he's
gotta be Opie but they'll probably owns
him but he's like one of the strongest
dudes in that anime and Videl and then
Friday I didn't talk to John we can been
about this yet but you know technically
anthem demos out so I don't know what
their plans were but that could be that
could be a loading screen stream as well
that was my whole weekend I occasionally
would be like I got in really the other
weekend I eventually got in uh-huh and I
was colleges like
I need this stuff I admit that you spend
more time with it but like the amount of
effort it took to get in like me
demoralizing
so the scary thing about this weekend
compared to last weekend is last weekend
was like quote-unquote the VIP demo
which you know in theory there were less
people all right
trying to get in there this week's the
open like everyone's gonna try to get it
it seems like there were weird issues
that they specifically fixed so I think
I still had the loading bugs but it was
just annoying to have to fix it though
gently which Kingdom Hearts is enough
ridiculous name that would be a Kingdom
Hearts 0.2 birth by Sleep a fragmentary
passage which is part of the Kingdom
Hearts 2.8 final chapters prologue
collection so many words I heard Kingdom
Hearts and in a lot of ways a lot of
words out whoa fireworks
oh yeah
I'm about this rage' light like a demon
bird that get out of turning into a
demon that's weird it's in in - it was
like a like a punishment system but in
here it's more of like a weird like
get-out-of-jail-free card
ooh control from remedy that's also I
don't know if that'll be everything
what's
yeah being a poster looking hard yes I
can blink the King of Hearts history of
I could spell history of
once again now I'm just reading some
question that seems like enemies love
getting wailed on and not very
aggressive don't feel like you're gonna
die in battle in this game there are
some tougher enemies where you do have
to be a little more on your toes but on
the difficulty of the game it's only
when you get to like number like I'm
honestly not playing very well because
I'm just sort of like I'm on the screen
I'm answering questions so I'm not
really like focused and I'm health the
health on the top right okay it
definitely feels like it's some standard
mode like it's pretty easy but there are
there's the harder mode which will
definitely be more of a challenge as
you're looking for you can also do cool
there's some cool extra stuff you can do
like you can set it so that you never
loved a lot no like hardcore like
challenge kind of thing whoa
you can also change it so that magic is
magic in this game works like a dozen
team hearts to whether you use it up and
then it has a cool-down and once that
cooldown goes away you can use it again
in Kingdom Hearts one magic would not
replenish unless you use an item or
killed yourself to bring back to that
and so you can actually set it to work
that way
which is a nice little touch so if they
have like options like more of like a
hardcore challenging spraying but yeah
it's sort of the standard difficulties
meant to be like accessible and fun
which I think that's sort of like the
way these games have a very low skill
floor but I mean like an incredibly high
skill ceiling right there there is a lot
of depth to the combat like I've seen
videos of people who are like those like
hardcore like DMC people's and they also
do like Kingdom Hearts videos and
farming crabs again we are a ship and we
didn't get those crabs when uh what's
his name this Johnny Depp disappeared
Michael transactions in this game no max
Fulton asking can i play Kingdom Hearts
3 if I've never played a Kingdom Hearts
game before yeah you can yeah you can
there's a story stuff at the beginning
that you can read to or watch videos I
have some ketchup you will definitely
not have a hard time following the main
plot but I would say that you can enjoy
the Disney stuff and appreciate it for
what it is it's self-contained and
gameplay wise it definitely it's very
accessible so if it's interesting if
it's something that interests you I'd
say it's worth giving it a shot yeah I
mean Ben's doing it blind pretty much I
was doing a blind I would love to hear
like it's gonna be interesting to see in
the next like week or so the people that
do try it and how they feel about it I'm
very curious but yeah it's kind of 50/50
I bet you there was a lucky day oh I bet
you there's a lucky I'm proud there is
thanks goofy oh I see it yes on the left
but only because he told me there was
one nearby
let's see nailed it
there we go what we wanna do you want
doing one more island or yeah we could
quickly do an island BRB trading re2 for
this how much we even get I feel like
trading in games you usually lose out on
a lot
I'm sorry too and maybe one the people
I've never been into trading in games
it's just not like my thing I like well
yeah I also typically only buy a game if
I like want to keep it do you miss
rental services or do you think that
just wouldn't work in I did used to use
why I had local stores I had that and
then I event for a while I didn't use
Gamefly Oh
which i think is still around actually
that's fee I think game flight was weird
though you had to like game the system
to like really truly take advantage of
it like I gave myself like like if you
wanted to get a new game when it came
out you would have to basically like
intentionally leave a slot open and then
ask for it to like guarantee to
guarantee you'll get it early but
there's a fun fact if you they had it
they had a like a program where when you
rented a game you could say hey I want
to keep this and then they let you like
pay a certain amount of money to keep it
if it was like a really old game would
usually be like five ten bucks
that's pretty if it was a new game it
would be like 40 bucks like 45 bucks
well if you were someone who like if you
timed it where you would get it right
away you would essentially get a brand
new copy that no one else has used yet
and then you could just say hey I want
to keep that for 45 bucks and then I
would save like 15 bucks that's pretty
good and then I would just immediately
get another game because then that slot
would be open minutes so you're playing
the game that was game fly yes I was
playing the game fly game to maximize my
my games I got and
money but honestly that was like enough
of a hassle to do and then it's like man
you were probably trying to find ways to
save 15 bucks exactly like helps you buy
the next game it's definitely not
something I am but that was a how I used
to try and game the system a little bit
i I used to blockbusters and the
warehouse videos of the world yeah we
had a Hollywood video I feel like oh
yeah Hollywood video - my friend used to
work there well my Hollywood video was
actually I don't make part of the
Hollywood video chain was just called
Hollywood video it was just like a or
maybe it was like they yeah the name but
it wasn't like a it was kind of its own
thing yeah cuz I feel like some of these
games you could actually get read for
like 5 10 bucks or whatever for like 5
days and get yours like my Hollywood
video let me actually run out Constance
- so like I as a kid I never won like an
Xbox or something I would be like I'm
gonna rent an Xbox and a game for like a
weekend oh yeah yeah yeah I just saw I'm
like reddit someone was like yeah I
remember these days it was like an n64
yeah in a little case that you could
just rent out you like rent rent it for
the weekend and then might play a game I
did that I've done that once I thing
forgot which console was though
Palace fun
all climb looks pretty satisfying yeah
it's fun I'm not doing much of a but you
can like do stuff like like that launch
thing I did with the ship you can do it
like I'm not I'm really not taking
advantage of some of the you know it's
style it's not styling as much as I
could be I would love you that s ray you
need those ratings I think I would love
to see some hardcore people who are like
really good at this game and they're
kind of crazy stuff it's like crazy men
maxing yeah there's never go look up
like yeah bleep oh you will they're
playing on like critical mode and
nonsense um agrees around here that it's
like the means this game is uh they just
say that all the time
[Music]
okay I know our yo-yos well you got the
go out ability later on yes yes you do
look at that I'll gamble oh my goodness
he's always be on the lookout he's a
tough especially this one because you
have to go all the different islands
this one so there's multiple and they
said yeah they're like all over the
place so it's a little bit of a tougher
one to get oh that was a lot crab yeah I
don't know why but I really want him to
use the key the way it should be enough
I just tapped the box open top I want
him to like turn it to the right calling
to stick to install Kingdom Hearts 3 we
got fast internet didn't take too long
it was only 32 gigs wasn't that big
that's not that big surprisingly first
for a game as big as this and that looks
as good as this I was shocked how small
the download was you got any more Hidden
Mickeys you need to go get it I lost all
of them for you I mean I wouldn't even
do it on this
if I was to do it all anyway I wouldn't
even do it on this is a bit further than
this I'm not gonna hae said I got it I
got a ps4 copy say okay if I ever when I
eventually replay this game at some
point I will replay it on the ps4 and
I'll just do it sounds good to me
where are you headed to now it's gonna
head to this luck islands okay well I
think we'll wrap up after the the luck
Island
Oh
yeah whoo excellent we are on the 1x
you're on the 1x what's nice it runs
well yeah it's the same size
that's the 32 gigs was for the one I'd
say yeah oh yeah that's right yes we'll
have like different installs depending
on if you're installing HD content game
looks good in 4k doesn't have HDR though
which is kind of weird but regardless of
that it still looks
and how come we can't shoot a volley
like that this alright I got - oh no
does that still count okay yeah Splash
Damage tidal wave
[Music]
fire
what was that gone-zo the toy store
world if you watch the other stream yeah
you'll see I did a stream last before a
show off the coast of Rome pirate's life
for me
[Music]
well cancer explore a lot at this place
it's about it okay you want to wrap it
up there then yeah sure all right sounds
good to me I still taste the game
spoiler free for the most part just kind
of running around yeah this is probably
one of the most unique worlds in the
game because you can get like the ship
stuff and you're going to different
islands and you get this like weird like
AC Black Flag vibe yeah that you don't
get with the other worlds but yeah
that's the game
awesome yes it's fun times check out to
mores review on site it's also up if you
haven't you want to catch up on Kingdom
Hearts before you play assuming you
haven't played yet and you want to know
what's up came with heart three not
Kingdom Hearts ooh Kingdom Hearts
history of is also up I'll post the link
again in YouTube chat here in a second
just find work by Lucy Richard and John
Luke yep check that out and yeah come
back tomorrow when we're streaming some
more games
we appreciate it I appreciate John Luke
for sacrificing his essay for this
stream yep so I'll probably go get him
lunch and until next time thanks so much
John Luke any last thoughts anything no
it's good game alright hope you guys
have fun with it peace